this video is brought to you by Rocky money more
on them after the reaction peeps citizens of the
reject Nation it is time for a trailer I
am very much excited for Kung Fu Panda 4
if you guys didn't know I covered the movies
with Coy jro right here on this very Channel
he was supposed to join me for this but he
decided to leave town jerk jerk enjoying
his holiday season anywh who guys what did
you think about this trailer I haven't seen
it yet but I'm excited to see what your
take is on in the comments go head type
it down below be sure to leave a like that
would be very much appreciated all right I
haven't slept and my wife still told me about
this trailer she's awesome I love her let's do
this it is time to take the next step
on your journey oh I'm excited I'm not
going to be the Dragon Warrior anymore
you will advance the spiritual leader
of the valley of Beast yes about
like oong inner peace keep your
surf off my cool dinner please dinner
with peas in a this is not working at
all yes I heard just coming back big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every Master
villain no one will dare question my power
not even the great wait Dragon Warrior she said
every Master V and most powerful shape-shifting
sorceress are they all coming back how do
I find this the chameleon I'm going to lead
you right front door they always make for
great villains chameleons it was against an
army then we'll just have to get an army of
our own I think Aquafina fits perfectly into
this world best Crooks and criminals
live here you're a wanted criminal you
sound surprised is it surprising now
you kids be careful of those fireworks
yikes some more zootopia Vibes this time
around being the Dragon Warrior it's who
I am about being a spiritual leader
what is it you're holding a cookie
you were chosen to become something
more than you already are the next
Evolution this really feels
like it's a full circle movie
quick and painless or slow and painful let's
K you finally met your match chameleon when not
so different you and I we're not so different
you stand back I'm going to kick my butt oh
it's got to change up the logo a little bit
it's going to be a cool fight oh
no I'm excited for it man can't wait to watch
it I'm so excited for it I really love the
second one's my personal favorite one of the
of the previous three but I I really enjoyed
all three of them all right let's talk about it I
got some thoughts got some thoughts before that a
word from Mar monter hey reject Nation you know
running real rejects is an incredible journey
is something I am truly grateful for but I got to
be real with you for one second here managing the
business side especially taxes to put it lightly
is incredibly overwhelming it's like navigating
a maze without a map and that's where our sponsor
rocket money comes in a sponsor when approached I
was so excited to work with because I kid you not
just last month I started using rocket money cuz
I needed to sort out this financial puzzle and
honestly it's been quite eye openening not just
for taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche of this
app is true I discovered apps and subscriptions
I have been paying for that I had not used in
ages it is like finding out you've been leaving
lights on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's like
a freaking Financial Guardian Angel it finds and
cancels those forgotten subscriptions monitors
your spending and even battles to lower your bills
thank God it's as if they're personally invested
in saving your hard-earned money like I try I
really try to be on top of my expenses but rocket
money they show me blind spots with a simple T
I can cancel unnecessary subscriptions they even
handle the hassle of negotiating with customer
services a relief my goodness to put it into
perspective rocket money has helped over 5 million
users save an average of $720 a year that's more
than just numbers it's a peace of mind so I invite
you my fellow rejects in taking control of your
finances so go ahead visit Rocky money.com reject
once again that's rocket money.com rejects let's
save together rocket money.com rejects I really
do stand by this app thank you for partnering
with us all right well that was a really really
fun trailer had a great time watching that one
um I really feel like this one's going to be
a full circle experience uh especially for our
main character po the fact that they're bringing
back TI long and seeing that they're getting a
new Dragon Warrior which is an interesting plot
point he's becoming like oolong or Shifu for that
matter he's becoming the embodiment of you know
his Master she's going from becoming you know just
a student who was discovered to becoming like the
fullon spiritual leader he's going to be embodying
the wisdom and experience he's gained over time
you KN so much about the Kung Fu Panda films have
also been about him balancing his identity is
both a funloving panda and a formidable Dragon
Warrior but this new film looks like it's going
to be incorporating those aspects a little bit
more to where he might become a more balanced and
wise leader and then having you know characters
like tied long returning it seems like they're
hinting at all of them returning in some aspect
could allow for Resolutions of past conflicts
possibly through Redemption arcs maybe which
could in turn perhaps uh deepen his relationship
with his biological and adoptive families it just
seems like overall we're going to be getting a
full circle experience justifying the existence
of a part 4 after so many years because the Kung
Fu Panda movies have always been about you know
selfis Discovery self-acceptance and his journey
into becoming the new spiritual leader essentially
like the ultimate Testament to his self accept
acceptance and understanding of his place in this
world and by finding and training the next Dragon
Warrior whoever that might be maybe it's Aqua I
don't know po completes his journey by becoming
that Mentor figure akin to shiu passing on that
knowledge and embodying the cycle of student
becoming the master and then you know that whole
thing with like influencing future Generations
just as as he was influenced by his predecessors
so sensely showcasing his Evolution from like an
enthusiastic dreamer to a wise leader and you're
fulfilling that prophetic role he was unwittingly
destined for since the first movie I mean it's
Jack Black he hasn't lost his touch with you know
Voice work he was just Bowser and practically
stole the show whenever he was voicing Bowser in
the Super Mario Brothers movie I'm very curious
about everything they're going to do this villain
chameleon uh seems formidable and a shape-shifting
type of villain adds something fresh to the
franchise I feel and it's Viola Davis who is a
phenomenal actor as well and she can be really
scary in liveaction so you know just bringing
that presence exuding Through The Voice work I can
only imagine she'll still bring that intimidation
factor I felt like ah God what is the name oh my
God the villain the second villain was my f like
every a lot of people prefer taong but my favorite
villain was the second one what is that guy's name
the bir um anyway I'm forgetting right now Shen
is it Shen let me just looking up it is Shen okay
all right you thought I couldn't pull it but I
didn't and then you know the interaction between
uh aquafina's character Zen it looks like it'll
be a really fun one with comedic and actionpack
sensibilities like one would expect and I think
Aquafina is a a wonderful voice edition Talent
just KIU Kuan is is another great exceptional
talent to provide to the Kung Fu Panda Legacy as
well Tai long I feel like they might be setting
up for a Redemption Arc of sorts feel like it
might just be too repetitive if they just brought
them back to be villainous yet again and if you're
going to bring back your your first movies villain
I think you got to you know make it a little bit
exciting by doing something creatively different
as opposed to just you know Cameo excitement but
you know it's the Kung Fu Panda franchise and all
the like the third one I really really liked a lot
it is my least favorite of the three I really
like the movie A Lot the first two I absolutely
love and I trust in this creative team very much
so this franchise has a really strong Legacy the
fourth one has a lot to live up to I love the
fact that they got Han Zimmer back to do the
score yet again there's a lot I'm really looking
forward to this overall uh yeah I'm excited for
the film man what do you guys think about the
trailer leave your thoughts down below probably
going to react to it right here on this channel
yeah let me let me get to putting this video
together for you all thank you again for being
here and we'll talk with you all soon reject
Nation